hi guys dr. Berg here I want to give you
a couple tips on what to do if you have
these dark circles underneath the eyes
okay just right here this is my image
right here it's not really just one
thing it could be coming from multiple
things many different causes and yes it
can be genetic okay but if it's not
genetic if it doesn't run in your family
here's some things you can look at
number one the sinuses if your sinuses
are congested with mucus you have a lot
of lymphatic congestion and the lymph
nodes go all around the eyes and that
can create a puffiness and also a back
up of the venous which is the veins
which is kind of blue which will look
kind of darker underneath the eyes
because you're seeing this congested
backflow of blood and lymph so if that's
the case that one of the best remedies
to clean out the sinuses would be some
of the nasal rinses that I'm gonna put
down below but there's a really good
remedy called colostrum which actually
corrects the immune system to improve
allergies and I'm gonna put a link down
below of some data on that but there's
another thing too that you can take
which is mormon tea now what is mormon
tea Mormon tea is a weak version of a
federer I don't know if you heard about
ephedra they took it off the market
because it increases adrenaline but
honestly the risk of that is so so small
compared to even aspirin out there the
amount of benefit that it did for people
with sinus congestion and lung pneumonia
and asthma and bronchitis I mean it's
very very effective it's been used for
over 2,000 years but of course you can't
patent it and it's very inexpensive but
if you monitor someone to make sure they
don't have high blood pressure and there
you don't take it when you're pregnant
it's totally fine but Mormon tea is a
really good thing to take in the early
part of the day to actually handle a
runny nose and to get rid of congestion
okay and of course the diet make sure
you're not doing any milk products that
could do it or any wheat products those
two will definitely back up the sinuses
and one more thing too if you ever go
out to a restaurant and you eat
something with meat and sugar or like
anything like a bun and hotdogs or a
burger
a bun and fries of our coke you are
going to create a lot of sinus
congestion from that and that could be
one of the causes too so as you clean up
the diet this will clear up too and then
we get to the liver okay if you're
detoxifying or your liver is toxic that
can create this appearance underneath
the eye as well
the best remedy is MIT milk thistle okay
that actually can repair liver damage so
it's quite amazing and it's very safe
and you won't get this detoxification
reaction from that many people who even
do colostrum or probiotics start having
an immune reaction and then they end up
getting this problem too so if you're
going to take anything for the first
time always take small amounts including
colostrum and I think you're gonna be
okay with this one all right then we get
to the adrenal adrenal fatigue with the
amount of stress that you have with the
amount of lack of sleep you're gonna
have the dark circles as well and so you
want to support the adrenal that's a
whole video in itself I put the link
down below but of course start out with
long walks every day don't sit in front
of the computer 24/7 good amounts of
sleep whatever you could do to improve
sleep is going to be a good thing in
fact that brings us to the next thing
which is sleep which is probably the
number one thing if you were to improve
what it would fix this dark circle
underneath the eyes so that's really
important and then vitamin D not only
helps the adrenal but it helps sleep as
well so Sun every day if you can get it
and then we have you know we talked
about walking decrease the stress and
lots of potassium foods potassium is the
physiological tranquilizer it relaxes
you it gets rid of sodium excess and
retention the fluid which could create
this as well but mainly the the sodium
potassium ratio issue if that's a
problem we'll create bags at the eyes
not necessarily discoloration but we
want to get you to sleep okay
so I'll put some links down below and
then allergies if you are allergic which
kind of gives us puts us in this
category as well high levels of vitamin
C would be very beneficial
for allergies and also colostrum is
another thing that actually corrects
allergies as well and there's other
things too I'll put some other links
down below but what you want to do is
you want to just see if there's anything
that kind of pop out for you and focus
on that part right now but the lining of
the skin underneath the eyes is very
very thin and you can very easily see
all the different the venous pooling in
there which is blue but it shows up as a
dark circle all right
so try some of these and put your
comments below thanks so much for
watching hey press the subscribe button
and let's keep you in the in the know
I'll keep you in the know no that
doesn't make sense
hey you probably already subscribed but
if you haven't press this little button
down below and I will keep you updated